C'était une technique pour marquer le suspense
Aujourd'hui on va faire quoi ? On va réagir à des gens qui réagissent à mes vidéos
Dans lesquelles parfois je réagis à d'autres trucs, c'est incroyable !
Je me suis toujours demander la gueule que font les gens, ou leurs réactions même
quand ils regardent une de mes vidéos
J'ai pu observer des fois des proches à moi qui regardaient des vidéos devant moi
qui voulaient voir ma dernière vidéo et qui la regardait devant moi
ce qui représente la situation la plus malaisante de la planète pour un youtuber
mais c'etais des proches
donc c'est différent
aujourd'hui je vais pouvoir voir votre visage à vous
qu'elle gueule vous faites quand vous regarder une de mes vidéos?
la vidéo à déjà 566 656 vues
elle date de plus d'un mois
Par ce que je suis toujours à l'heure
Mais la bonne nouvelle c'est que je ne l'aie pas vue
par ce que je me réservais la possibilitée
de faire cette vidéo là si j'avais envie
et aujourd'hui j'en aie envie c'est incroyable j'ai prevu  c'est fouu
allez c'est parti !
*Musique d'intro de la chaîne doozy*
AAAHH NAN, NAN, NAN !
ok on change, aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour un petit jeu
qui s'appelle piconocoli
on a une lycéenne
un modele photo
Oh Philippe, on est modele photo dans la vie Philippe
PS: sous-titre by MlleIlona *clin d'oeil furtif*
Marine 19ans étudiante
shams 17ans lycéen
Junie 19 ans étudiante
Fille: J'ai peut-être un humour de merde
Fille: et je suis peut-être très immature
Fille: Mais franchement il me fait trop rire
J'ai peut-être un attend quoi ?!
fille : j'ai peut-être un humour de merde je suis peut-être trés imature
j'ai peut-être un humour de merde et je suis peut-être trés immature
alors si il y a bien 2 mots qui représente la chaîne c'est celà, bien joué
Vidéo de squeezie : aujourd'hui nous allons mettre à l'épreuve notre capacité à être ou pas mal à l'aise devant une situation
AH NAN, c'est ouf !
je réagit à des gens qui réagissent à moi qui réagit
*Rigole*
ça n'a pas trop de sens de montrer ça dans le sens où ce n'est pas une vidéo que j'ai fait de toutes pièces
je regarde juste d'autres vidéos
comme hactuellement d'ailleurs
*Bruits de la vidéo*
*Rigole*
je ne m'attendais pas à cette réponse
il ne fallait pas dire ça
tu viens de perdre tous tes amis là
Homme de la vidéo: c'est juste pour savoir quand vous allez mettre la deuxième couche.
ce malaise
Garçon: ho la la
c'est ultra gênant, le malaise est palpable dans la pièce
et il le ressent alors c'est encore pire je me sent mal pour lui en faite
doozy, si je puis-je me permettre, ils ne réagissent pas à mes vidéos
il réagissent à un chauve qui fait une blague dans un dîner presque parfait
c'est un mauvais choix de vidéos là
HO LEEEEEEES
AHHHHHHHHHHH !
la on est bien
Squeezie 2: vous voyez ce génie qui sort de sa lampe et qui sourit aux gens qui vont sur ce p****** de site web
on va le faire redescendre sur terre un peu... Par ce que là *siffle*
ah nan pas lui
ah, akinator j'adorais jouer à ça quand j'étais petit
OH BAH OUI ! Oui monsieur, il y avait ça et adibou on connait bien
Garçons: akinator je trouvais ça trop cool, c'est marrant et puis j'ai jamais compris comment ça marchait
c'est très simple, c'est un arbre de possibilités si tu réponds à une question ça va t’amener vers d'autres questions
et ta rechercher s'affine au fur et à mesure que tu réponde à des questions, jusqu'à tomber sur des questions hyper précise
par exemple ton youtuber à t'il un chat qui s'appelle Jumbo ?
voilà j'ai des parts dans la société akinator
on va pas en parler
Yo tout le monde c'est squeezie aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour une petite compilation de jeux gratuits
On commence tout de suite avec boxman begin
Garçon: Elle date cette vidéo
Bah totalement mec, attend c'est abusé. Viens on la regarde pas et on se casse faire du model photo
ensemble
apprend moi
Fille: Il était encore enfant, à oui et il avait toujours pas une voix VIRILE °^°
J'ai donc maintenant une voix virile
elle la dit les gars
vous avez vu je prends une grosse voix inconsciament, comme si je voulais vous prouver
nan mais c'est facilement constatable les progrès en niveau de virilité sur la chaîne youtube, euh... son présent
Garçon: quand il était ado, il était beaucoup, beaucoup trop énergique
bah enfaite c'est après qu'il est commencé à ce calmer un peu plus que j'ai commencé à regarder vraiment ses vidéos
parce que il y avait de l'humour mais mais quand même un côté un peu plus virile
alors que là c'étais, une impression de voir un petit jeune de 17 qui faisait des vidéos et qui essayais de mettre toute  l'énergie qu'il avait pour réussir
C'est exactement ça
enfaîte, j'ai juste liée au fait que je ne savais pas vraiment comment faire marrer et ducoup il fallait en faire des caisses, des tonnes dans les vidéos
et ne plus du tous être soit même pour vous faire marrer
alors que maintenant bah quand un truc me fait chier ça ce voit que ça me fait chier vous voyez qu'il y a moins de vannes moins de trucs
mais du coup c'est beaucoup plus naturel et spontané
alors que avant c'était AOUH AEH AUH AUEH !
Tous le temps et au bout d'un moment c'est un peu relou
alors que moi maintenant j'aime bien faire des vidéos où on est beaucoup plus poser
il a quand même de l'humour, mais on est quand même plus "nous même"
quand tu vas faire tes courses tu vas pas être : WOUAH JE VAIS PAYER, YA UN TAPIS ROULANT C'EST INCROYABLE 2€ LA BAGUETTE  WOUAAHH !
même faire cette imitation ça me fait chier.
j'étais vraiment beaucoup plus comme ça et je suis content de voir une personne qui fait partit de ce groupe que ne regardait pas du tout les vidéos avant
et qui s'est mit à les regarder, et qui maintenant est spectateur de la chaîne youtube, donc ça me fait super plaisir
CHUI CONTENT, TRÈS CONTENT !
*Bruit de la vidéo*
Jeune Homme: C'est pas un jeu d'horreur ça ?
Fille: de base je ne jouerais pas à ce genre de jeux par ce que je serais que ça me fait peur
et du coup tu regardes des gens jouer à ce jeu. Comme ça tu as moins peur
Garçon: Sur ce nouveau format qu'il a créé un peu plus tard, il est plus poser et il a quand même son humour donc c'est plus agréable
P****** mais tu veux me pecho
il est model photo, il est virile, il me fait que des compliments. Mais vient, vient traverse cette porte, rejoins moi
*Cris de Squeezie dans la vidéo de la vidéos*
Garçon : J'aime pas ça, j'aime pas ça
Attend j'en peu plus d'entendre ce cris, pfff mec
on dirait un singe
Squeezie 2: eh ouais, surprise bande de s******* c'est pas squeezie qui est la on a prit les rennes
Jimmy: Aller on est là pour clasher le youtube game français
Garçon: J'adore leurs chapeaux
C'est quoi ces remarques, mais lui c'est un sniper, il sort des remarques que personnes aurait vue venir
Fille : On dirait un petit rap mais version sheap
Qu'est-ce que tu insinue ? C'est pas par ce que on laisse nos étiquettes sur nos fringues qu'on va les rendre
peut-être
Fille: c'était un peu long, je pense que si il avait fait sur 2 ou 3 personnes maxi ça serait passé mais bon c'est un peu ^^ relou
Oh bah ok, je m'en fous, je m'en fous pourquoi ? Par ce que moi y'a un model photo qui veut me pecho, ok pas toi !
qu'est ce qui le caractérise plus selon toi ?
Fille: je pense que c'est l'humour par ce que il prend vachement tout, même lui même au second degrés
enfin, il se traite toujours de fragile, bon c'est vrai on va pas se le cacher ^^
Fille "2": Moi je pense que c'est la fait qu'il soit très humain
Bah, son énergie, sa diversité et je pense aussi sa façon de voir toujours le côté positif des choses et sa persévérance surtout
Philippe, j'aimerai te dire aujourd'hui, j'apprécis beaucoup tous ce que tu dis envers moi, c'est touchant, tu es touchant
je t'invite donc si tu le souhaite, PFFF C'est chiant, à c'est le moment des éloges, alors là j'ai toujours pas trop su comment réagir au gens
qui font des compliments à part dire : euh merci, et être gêner
bah, merci, vous êtes très touchants, ou alors ce que vous dites c'est hyper touchant, ou alors j'aimerai vous toucher.....
Quel type de vidéo as-tu préféré ?
Le malaise, ça s'était trop marrant
Les vidéos malaisantes du début
*Alors qu'est-ce qui vous fait rire dans les vidéos de squeezie ? Alors j'aime vraiment quand dans ses vidéos, il n'y a pas que lui par ce que lui il est pas drôle en fait.
du coup j'aime vraiment ce qui est drôle et qu'il met dans ces vidéos mais qui ne vient pas de lui
Fille: J'adore quand il fait des gameplay sur tous un jeu en entier et comme ça tu suis les épisodes, tu as envie de savoir la suite.
THE LAST GUARDIAN ! (c'est vrai) ah ça me fait plaisir aussi de voir quelqu'un me dire ça p******* par ce que mine de rien
vous êtes moins nombreux à aimer les séries comme ça, sur un jeu vidéo surtout quand le jeu est très poétique et que c'est pas du tous drôle ou de l'horreur
ça fait plaisir d'entendre ça c'est fous
que pensez vous de son humour ?
Garçon: c'est un bon humour, un peu "beauf" par moment mais c'est comme ça que je l'aime
Fille: bah je pense qu'il se prend vachement au second degrés et il ne se prend pas la tête et c'est ça qui est drôle. Même si après il y a des blagues lourdes
mais sinon j'aime bien
Fille "2": c'est pourrit, mais des fois c'est tellement pourrit
Mais tes vilaine toi
fille: c'est marrant, c'est mignon
ah ok
Fille: quelques fois c'est drôles et des fois je ne comprend pas et ça me fait pas rire du tout
Fille: Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, si tu aimes squeezie comme moi, hésite pas à mettre un petit pouce bleu
et abonne toi
et voilà les amis c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéos (et des sous-titres qui sont LONG à faire mais c'est pour toi :p)
de réactions, de réaction à des gens qui réagissent
ça ma fait super marré de voir des gens regarder mes vidéos comme ça, voir leurs réactions ce qu'ils penses ....
c'est toujours enrichissant, déjà par ce que ça fait des vues = €€€€€€
et ensuite par ce que cela permet de vraiment ce rendre compte de ce que les gens penses voir
je pense qu'il ne faut pas non plus trop ce focaliser là dessus et par ce que sinon tu vas faire que ce que les gens et  je vais prendre 0 risque
et je vais pas non plus faire ce que moi j'aime
je veux vraiment répondre aux attentes des gens
et du coup en faisant ça tu surprend même plus les gens et tu t'épanoui de moins en moins
mais là ça ma fait du bien car ils connaissaient déjà tous ma chaîne youtube donc ils aimaient plus ou moins
mais je me demande si on fait des vidéos réactions comme ça à des gens qui sont complètement déconnecter de tous ça
genre des cinquentenaire (bravo la langue française)
et même des parents quoi
je pense qu'ils répondraient tous à fait autre chose
ça serait marrant de voir le choc des génération
Bon bah voilà ça m'aura fait hyper plaisir de faire cette vidéo et puis vos réactions elles sont rigolote donc à la base je voulais vraiment pas la faire
par ce qu'on m'avait dit que les réactions dans les vidéos étaient pas dingue
franchement si, c'étais cool (Lucas est heureux)
A très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéos merci d'avoir regarder, portez-vous bien, tchao tous les monde et pissss !
Ps: J'ai mis du temps à faire les sous-titres ~3h30 et je suis désolée pour les fautes